et me tuer il poétesse tu travaille très
dur à tes poèmes tu veux que chaque
verre soit parfait mais ce que je veux
c'est l'imparfait ce que je veux c'est
toi
[Musique]
nous vivons des temps très sûr de la
violence de la douleur
si cela que je veux dire avec ma poésie
ces mots ne compte pas pointe
j'ai tellement de poèmes en tnt avec ce
conflit dans notre famille j'ai même pas
pu les mettre par écrit
cette famille est une farce mon mariage
est un mensonge
décidément la guerre de sécession dh
tout
c'est comme si cette guerre avait surgi
de nulle ça c'est parce qu il était
manifeste qu'on était en train de faire
fausse route
tu es la seule qui soit assez brave pour
affronter la vérité
alors n'essayez pas de me faire cette
fois aux espoirs et si l'espoir c'est
tout ce que nous avons
ma famille va vite applaudissions cuir
mais rien de ce que je fais n'améliore
crois que ce soit
tu crois te battre pour quelque chose
mais en fait tu ne fait que prendre la
fuite
[Musique]
faut être un grand poète il faut
ressentir tous cons
le plaisir la souffrance l'ombre et le
soleil oui quelquefois un pour trois
mois
non mais c'est quoi
d'où elle te vient cette passion
peut pas vivre sans toi
sans toi
veut faire quelque chose qui importe
ne vous en faites pas emily dickinson va
vous aider
dans la future du disque un célèbre
emily dickinson et est le type même de
la fille triste
[Musique]